hi everyone
this is professor under science and
today i want to tell you about
quasi-classical states of the quantum
harmonic oscillator
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics when we think about a
harmonic oscillator what comes to mind
is a back and forth motion for example
that of a mass
attached to a spring however when we
think about the energy eigenstates of a
quantum harmonic oscillator for example
the ground state gaussian they are
stationary
this means that they don't describe
anything like the oscillations that we
have for the classical harmonic
oscillator so the question that we're
going to ask
today is does the quantum harmonic
oscillator
actually oscillate and what we're going
to find is that
it does but we need a coherent state
to see those oscillations today we're
going to explore
how the coherent states of a quantum
harmonic oscillator
are the states that most closely
resemble the motion that we observe
in a classical harmonic oscillator and
that is why we often give
another name to coherent states we call
them quasi-classical states
so let's go we're seeking quantum states
of the harmonic oscillator whose
behavior resembles the oscillatory
motion
of a classical oscillator so let's
therefore start with a quick refresher
of the classical harmonic oscillator
i'm going to simply quote the relevant
results but most of you will have
encountered this system before
and if you haven't then any classical
mechanics textbook will have the
relevant background
first of all the position of a classical
particle in a harmonic oscillator
follows an oscillatory motion of
amplitude x0
and frequency omega where the phase phi
depends on the initial conditions
second the momentum of the classical
particle is given by the mass
multiplied by the time derivative of the
position
which gives this pre-factor times the
sine function
and third the total energy of the system
is equal to the kinetic energy part plus
the potential energy part
inserting the expressions above for
momentum and position we get this for
the kinetic energy
and this for the potential energy we can
cancel this mass
with this power and we can then rewrite
the whole expression as equal to this
common factor
multiplying the sine squared plus the
cosine squared
this bracket is equal to 1 and the whole
expression simplifies to this constant
factor
therefore although the values of the
kinetic and potential energies change
over time
the sum stays constant
and these three quantities here fully
characterize the classical harmonic
oscillator
what about the quantum harmonic
oscillator
remember that the hamiltonian h is equal
to the kinetic energy
plus the potential energy and we can
also write it down in terms of ladder
apparatus
or in terms of the number operator
the eigenvalue equation of the
hamiltonian is h
acting on the ket n equal to e n times
the kit
n and the eigenenergies are quantized
where n is a non-negative integer
so how can we connect the quantum
oscillator with its classical
counterpart
we can describe quantum states in a
variety of ways
one example is in terms of wave
functions which
capture the extended nature of quantum
states in space
this is fundamentally different from the
point particles of classical mechanics
however from the video on erinfest's
theorem
we know that the expectation values of
operators such as position and momentum
can be used to connect the quantum and
classical world
therefore in this video we're going to
look
into the behavior of the expectation
values of quantum operators
and compare them with the motion of the
classical particles
the expectation value of the position
operator in an energy eigenstate
n can be written like this by using the
expression of the position operator in
terms of the ladder operators
if you cannot remember how to write down
the position operator in terms of ladder
operators
you can find all the details in the
corresponding video that is linked in
the description
this calculation requires the
expectation value of the lowering
operator
and remember that the action of the
lowering operator on an energy
eigenstate
removes one quantum of energy this means
that we get this for the expectation
value
which vanishes because the energy
eigenstates
form an orthonormal set
similarly the expectation value of the
raising operator
vanishes and these results imply that
the expectation value of the position
operator vanishes
for any energy eigenstate
as energy eigenstates are stationary
states
their expectation value is time
independent
and so basically stays at zero
at all times we can make an analogous
argument to show that the expectation
value of the momentum operator with
respect to an energy eigenstate
also vanishes at all times
for the expectation value of the
hamiltonian with respect to an energy
eigenstate
we trivially get the corresponding
energy eigenvalue
so let's compare our two scenarios side
by side
we have the classical case and the
quantum harmonic oscillator in an energy
eigenstate
the position of a classical particle in
a harmonic oscillator
changes according to a cosine and the
expectation value of a quantum particle
in an energy eigenstate
is always zero now turning to the
momentum the classical particle obeys
this equation in terms of
a sine and the expectation value of the
quantum particle in an energy eigenstate
is always zero now finally the classical
energy is
constant and the quantum energy in an
energy eigenstate is also constant
so what can we learn from this when we
think about the classical harmonic
oscillator what comes to mind is a back
and forth motion
for example a mass attached to a spring
in this back and forth motion the
position here
and momentum here of the classical
particle
change sinusoidally where the energy
here stays constant
for the energy eigenstates of the
quantum harmonic oscillator we also have
a constant energy here
but the position and the momentum
do not resemble at all the back and
forth motion that we expect
for a harmonic oscillator they're both
equal to zero
at all times and this prompts the
question of whether the quantum harmonic
oscillator is actually
oscillating at all what we will do in
the rest of the video is to show
that we can make the quantum harmonic
oscillator oscillate
but to do so the system needs to be in
the right
state and lo and behold it turns out
that what we need
is coherent states
let's have a quick refresher on
coherence dates but as always you can
find
full details by following the links in
the description
a coherent state alpha is defined as an
eigenstate
of the lorrying operator unlike the
hamiltonian
the lowering operator is not a hermitian
operator so the eigenvalues alpha
are in general complex numbers coherent
states can be written explicitly
in the basis of energy eigenstates of
the quantum laminar oscillator
and the resulting expression is that
alpha
is equal to this brief factor times this
infinite sum over the energy eigen
states
we've already seen that individual
energy eigenstates behave very
differently to the classical oscillator
coherent states are an infinite
superposition
over energy eigenstates and as we'll see
today
this precise superposition is such that
we will get a motion that
does resemble the classical motion as
closely as
possible and this is the reason why
coherent states are also called
quasi-classical states
as we've already done for energy
eigenstates to explore the connection
between
coherent states and the classical
harmonic oscillator
we'll need to evaluate the expectation
values of the position
momentum and energy operators in a
coherent state
before we can do that we're going to
derive a number of expectation values of
combinations of ladder operators
that will facilitate our calculations in
the rest of the video
to do so we will write again the
defining equation of a coherent state
and we also consider the corresponding
expression in geospace
to get this we take the usual approach
of turning all kets into brass
here and here all scalars into the
complex conjugates
here and all operators into their
adjoints
the first expectation value that we want
is that of the lowering operator
so using the definition of a coherent
state in state space
we end up with alpha we can use a
similar approach to deduce that
the expectation value of any power of
the lowering operator
is equal to alpha to that power
for the corresponding expectation value
for the raising operator
we can use the definition of a coherent
state in the dual space
and we end up with the complex conjugate
of alpha
and similarly the expectation value of
any power
of the rating operator is equal to alpha
star
to that power the next expectation value
that will prove useful is that of a
dagger
a we can use the definition of a
coherent state
in dual space here and that in state
space
here to end up with the absolute
value squared of alpha
next i want to consider the expectation
value of
a a dagger in this case we need to
remember from the video on ladder
operators
that the commutator between a and a
dagger
is equal to 1. this implies that
a a dagger is equal to 1 plus
a dagger a using this result we can
rewrite our expectation value as the sum
of these two terms
this is the expectation value above so
we end up with 1 plus the absolute
value squared of alpha
this is a summary of the various
expectation values that we've just
derived we'll use them thoroughly in the
rest of the video
so a good idea may be to take a snapshot
or maybe copy them down so that you can
easily follow
the rest of the derivations
let's start with the expectation value
of the position operator with respect
to a coherent state the first step is to
write this out using the expression of
the position operator in terms of ladder
operators
which is a result that should look
familiar from the video on
ladder operators we can then take out
the scalar prefactor
multiplying the expectation value of the
lowering operator and of the rating
operator
from our derivations earlier we know
that this is equal to alpha
and this is equal to alpha star
therefore we end up with the pre-factor
times alpha plus alpha star
or using the properties of complex
numbers we can rewrite this
as this new prefactor times the real
part
of alpha for the expectation value
of x squared we again write it out first
in terms of ladder operators
and then we take the scalar terms out as
a pre factor
multiplying four terms the expectation
value of a squared
the expectation value of a dagger
squared the expectation value of a
a dagger and the expectation value of
a dag array using the earlier
derivations we know that this
is alpha squared this is our star
squared
this is one plus alpha times half a star
and this is alpha times alpha star
putting everything together we end up
with the pre-factor
times these four terms
and this expression simplifies to the
pre-factor times
alpha plus alpha star all squared
plus one
from these results we can now easily
evaluate the root mean square deviation
of the position operator in a coherent
state
which is given by the usual formula
substituting our expression for the
expectation value of x squared
and our expression for the expectation
value of x
all squared we then see that we can
cancel this term
with this term and we end up with the
square root of h bar
over 2 m omega and interestingly the
root mean square deviation does not
depend on alpha
let's now turn to the time dependence of
the expectation value of the position
operator
let's imagine that the state of our
system at time 0 is a coherent state
alpha 0.
we know that alpha 0 is in general a
complex number
so we're going to write it out using
euler's formula as equal to this
magnitude
times its face which i label by phi
we then know from the video on coherent
states that the state of the system
at a later time t is also a coherent
state
characterized by the eigenvalue alpha of
the lowering operator
where alpha is equal to alpha 0 times
the exponential of
minus i omega t inserting this
expression for alpha 0
in here we can rewrite alpha as equal to
the magnitude
of alpha 0 times this phase factor
with this we can use this expression up
here for the expectation value of the
position operator
to write it at time t as equal to
this multiplying the expression that we
just got for alpha
and the corresponding complex conjugate
remembering that the sum of the
exponential of i delta
with its complex conjugate is equal to
two times the cosine
of delta we can rewrite our expression
as equal to this pre-factor
times the magnitude of alpha zero times
the cosine of omega t
minus five now this form should look
very familiar
if you've studied the classical harmonic
oscillator
but before we discuss this in more
detail let's first look
at the expectation value of the momentum
operator
the calculation of the expectation value
and root mean square deviation of the
momentum operator essentially
follows the same lines as the one that
we just did for the position operator
therefore i will simply quote the result
but feel free to give it a go
do the calculations in detail and it
will be good practice
the expectation value of the momentum
operator with respect to a coherent
state
is equal to this pre-factor times alpha
minus alpha star
it can also be rewritten as equal to
this other pre-factor
times the imaginary part of alpha
for the expectation value of p squared
we get this pre-factor
times one minus alpha minus alpha star
all squared finally putting these
results together
we can also evaluate the root mean
square deviation of the momentum
operator
which is equal to the square root of mh
bar omega
over 2. and note that this result is
again
independent of alpha for the time
dependent
we again consider an initial state that
is a coherent state alpha 0
and then the status later time t is
another coherent state alpha where alpha
is related to alpha 0
by this expression we then have that the
expectation value of
momentum at time t is equal to this
pre-factor
multiplying the magnitude of alpha 0
times the sine of omega t
minus phi this final expression probably
looks very familiar
but let's look at the energy before we
say more
for the expectation value and root mean
square deviation of the hamiltonian
we're again
only going to quote the final results
but again
feel free to have a go at the derivation
yourself
expectation value of the hamiltonian is
equal to h bar omega times the absolute
value of
alpha squared plus one half
the expectation value of h squared is
equal to h bar squared
omega squared multiplying alpha to the
power 4
plus 2 times alpha to the power of 2
plus
1 4. with these results
we can also evaluate the root mean
square deviation of the hamiltonian
and we get h bar omega times the
absolute value
of alpha the time dependence of the
expectation value of the energy is
actually trivial
we again consider the state of the
system at time 0
to be the coherent state alpha 0 and we
then know that the state of the system
at a later time t
is also proportional to a coherent state
characterized by alpha
where alpha is equal to alpha 0 times
this phase factor
from this expression up here for the
expectation value
of the hamiltonian we see that it only
depends on the magnitude of alpha
and this means that the expectation
value of the hamiltonian
at time t is equal to this
which means that the expectation value
of the energy of the system
in a coherent state is time independent
right so we compared the classical
oscillator
with the energy eigenstates of the
quantum oscillator at the very beginning
of the video
and we concluded that their behavior was
very different
we're now finally ready to compare the
classical harmonic oscillator
with a new family of states of the
quantum harmonic oscillator
coherent states the position of a
classical particle in a harmonic
oscillator
changes according to a cosine and the
expectation
value of a quantum particle in a
coherent state
also changes according to a cosine
turning to momentum the classical
particle or base
this equation in terms of a sine and the
expectation value of the quantum
particle in a coherent state
also changes sinusoidally
finally the classical energy is constant
and the quantum energy in a coherent
state is also
constant so
what can we learn from this while we
didn't have the back and forth
oscillation that we expected when the
quantum particle was in an energy
eigenstate
we now see that the quantum particle
does indeed oscillate
when it is in a coherent state comparing
the classical position here with the
expectation value of the position in the
coherent state here
we see that if we identify the amplitude
x0 of the classical motion with this
expression in terms of alpha 0
it then follows that the classical
motion is exactly reproduced
by the motion of the expectation value
of the quantum particle in a coherent
state
interestingly using the same relation
between x 0 and alpha 0
we conclude that the time evolution of
the momentum
in the classical motion is again exactly
reproduced by the quantum motion
in the coherent state
so this means that when the quantum
harmonic oscillator
is in a coherent state the expectation
values of position and momentum
oscillate in such a way that they
exactly reproduce the classical motion
what about the energy in this case we
get that the classical energy is equal
to the quantum energy
minus one-half times h-bar omega
so energy is a little trickier both
classical and quantum energies are
constant over time
that's right but the magnitude differs
by this term you might remember that
this term is what we called the zero
point energy of the quantum harmonic
oscillator
which is a purely quantum phenomenon
for classical oscillators the magnitude
of alpha zero is much much larger
than the zero point energy which means
that to a very good approximation
the energy in a quantum coherent state
is also the same
as the classical energy putting all of
this together
the coherent states of a quantum
harmonic oscillator
are the quantum states that most closely
follow the motion of a classical
particle
in a harmonic oscillator and this is a
reason why coherent states are also
called
quasi-classical states coherent states
also called quasi-classical states are
what we need to make
a quantum harmonic oscillator actually
oscillate
to see this more explicitly you should
check out our video on the wave
functions of the coherent states
and as always if you liked the video
please subscribe